hi everyone its charlie surprise
surprise we just found out that there
was an alternate ending to game throws
season 8 episode 6 so there's this
finale moment they said it was going to be
very different in their original version
of events so I'll explain what that is
because it involves a small change early
in the season that then causes ripple
effects changing a lot of things in
subsequent episodes so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Game of Thrones A Song of Ice
and Fire videos obviously I'll be doing
videos for the Game of Thrones prequel
series the Blood Moon TV show as we get
more information about that there's a
new round of the HBO now giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video and because it was a little bit of
confusion on the last game of Thrones
prequel video that I did a couple of
days ago dan and Dave are not involved
with the prequel series creatively any
of them there are four different prequel
series they won't have anything to do on
any level with anything that's going on
during those careful for spoilers for
everything through Game of Thrones
season AIDS so I just did this like a
top 10 list so we start in episode 3
this is where they start making changes
to the original plot starting with
number 10 originally sir Jorah is going
to survive the Battle of Winterfell
while protecting Daenerys from all these
whites while they're still trying to
end the night King in the White Walkers
so biggest change early on is that sir
Jorah survives the battle heading into
episode 4 number 9 everyone is
celebrating their victory in the Great
Hall here sir Jorah is lauded as a hero
of the north just like all the other
major characters that survive so he does
the same type of thing that tyrion is
doing during the feast in the Great Hall
I mean he's not being really mean to
Brienne he's off drinking with other
people leaving tenaris by herself
because he's being cheered by all these
northern soldiers remember Jorah is from
the north he's a north man but he's been
living in exile this whole time because
he fled Ned Stark's justice so the nord
hated him the little bear really wasn't
hot on him they sort of had that final
moment together
she still winds up dying during the
battle because she refused to go down to
the crypts even though she might not
have been a whole lot safer down in the
crypts but because there's no leader of
Bear Island any more it also provides
this little wrinkle potential future
alternate choices for sir Jorah like
would he come back and lead his people
because they'll need a new leader at
Bear Island eventually after this is all
once Daenerys wins the Iron Throne so
when you get these Daenerys scenes of
her just slowly starting to realize how
alone she is she's starting to lose the
people around her she doesn't have that
circle of support she freaks out even
more when she sees Sir Jorah with his
North man because she knows his history
so she also starts to worry that he's
going to leave her as well once this is
all done oh he's going to go back to his
people because they want him back now
and even though they didn't make it very
clear during this - it sounds like
Mohsen day had told Daenerys that she
intended to leave with grey worm when
this was all done - so it's a little
more clear about why Daenerys is acting
this way when she's talking to Jon Snow
because she starts to think that things
are crumbling around her at this bid for
the Iron Throne because this is still
relatively early in the season the rest
of the night goes out relatively
similarly Jon Snow still has that
conversation with her or freaking out
telling him not to tell anyone else
he still winds up telling the stark
children Sansa still begins her gambit
telling Tyrion knowing that it will
cause him to go tell Varys and start to
crumble support for Daenerys within her
camp so 8:00 the next morning when
they're having their battle planning
meeting Daenerys refuses to wait for
their armies to recuperate after the
last battle goes down relatively similar
as the scene happened before except
surger is also there now in unlike
Tyrion she still trusts Jorah and he's
in good standing with her so she
actually listens to what he says he's
cautioning her to maybe wait a hot
minute before they head down to
Dragonstone so it has this layer of
unease to Daenerys when she's adamant
about them going down so that finally
they decide Jon Snow still makes the
same choice doing that ned stark thing
will honor our promise we made to our
queen will support her with all of our
forces so when she loses Ragle it hits
her even harder because trusted adviser
Sir Jorah was telling her not to do this
the rest of episode 4 goes down
relatively similarly with her losing
Ragle to Euron's 360noscope scorpion
bolts missandei still gets captured by
Euron but because sir Jorah was on the
boat with tyrion and varys in this scene
here because he's still alive at this
point he also becomes part of this
subplot with Varys trying to build
support for Jon Snow taking the Iron
Throne over Daenerys but at this point
still relatively early in the story he's
even more team Daenerys than Tyrion is
so remember Tyrion at the end of episode
four
isn't having any of Eris's treason plot
bears starts sending his letters out
around the realm trying to tell all the
lords that Jon Snow is the true heir
basically explaining his story he's the
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
stark he's the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne in a much better option for the
realms and Daenerys he's basically
trying to tell everyone that Daenerys is
slowly getting out of control so at the
beginning of episode five number seven
Daenerys storyline is relatively similar
with her in this just really disheveled
state still broken up over ray Cole's
death she figures out about Pierce's
plot still mistakenly blames Jon Snow
for everything initially but when she
goes to blame
Tyrion for indexer Jorah speaks up for
him and they explained that it was Varys
is doing all along so this is her
starting to turn on Sir Jorah as well
even though she still kind of trusts him
she still feels really close to him she
doesn't hate him quite as much as she
hates tyrion in this moment here six
Varys still tries to get John Snow to do
it treason with him fails and that gets
executed making Jorah feel even more
conflicted just like Jon Snow and they
sort of had this parallel emotional arc
over the next couple of episodes is the
near slowly spirals downward so sir
Jorah is also slowly starting to feel
conflicted about what she's doing five
Daenerys till hoax out on King's Landing
would drag on after she realizes she's
won and the taste of victory is bitter
in her mouth she still feels completely
alone because by this point in the
episode she feels like surgery isn't
loyal to her anymore either Jon Snow has
already rejected their relationship and
she suspects that tyrion has been
secretly giving her bad advice this
whole time on purpose in an attempt to
sabotage her so he just lands on her
even harder in this moment here where
she just feels completely by herself in
her victory and then you go to Dany she
feels empty
it wasn't what she thought it was it's
not enough every single thing that's
letter to this point and there she is
alone we've all got this part of us that
part that goes I'm going to put that
chocolate cake down and I'm going to walk
away we come up against these moral
conundrums all the time you know sank
chocolate and moral conundrum eat as
much cake as you want but those
things that you wrestle with in yourself
she knows she has won this war it's in
that moment when she makes the decision
to make this personal predictably number
four as you would expect after this she
burns King's Landing everyone around her
to the ground and Sir Jorah has the same
reaction to it all that Jon Snow has
just like this is all wrong what's going
on here this is terrible it wasn't
supposed to be like this this isn't what
we planned
so Jorah is with Jon Snow in the thick
of it while this is a goal going on and
he starts to realize that they really
need to pump the brakes before things
get even worse for the realm we start in
episode six number three just like Jon
Snow he still cares about Daenerys a lot
he still seems like he's team Daenerys
they tried to get that across with the
Jon Snow character I'll address that in
a second because it wasn't always clear
what was going on between the two of
them but it's not till after she gives
her best
Hitler speech to the unsullied and the
Dothraki about liberating the world
quote-unquote
with a never-ending war and throws
Tyrion in prison that Jorah
also tries to convince Jon Snow to stop
Daenerys but just to be clear it's still
Tyrion who gives Jon Snow the call to
action to end Daenerys George just
wants to stop Daenerys pump the brake he
doesn't want to see her dead because he
still loves her a lot but he hates to
see her become this really big tyrant
that it seems like she's turning into so
of course all three of them Tyrion Jon
Snow and Jorah are thrown in prison
after Jon Snow ends Daenerys Jorah for
being complicit in Jon Snow's actions
even though he wasn't the person that
actually told Jon Snow to go end
Daenerys
to the scene of Tyrion facing the Great
Council alone happens pretty much the
same way where a Yara Greyjoy in Gendry
are pissed at Jon for ending Daenerys
and want justice just like grey worm
they also needed a couple extra lines of
dialogue from some of these Daenerys
supporters on the council to make it a
little clearer why Jon Snow had to go to
the wall because otherwise why wouldn't
he just come back after grey worm in the
unsullied left so Yara was team Daenerys
during this council because she had
previously offered to allow the Iron
Islands independence from the Seven
Kingdoms after she won the throne you've
brought us a hundred ships from the iron
fleet with men to Salem in return I
expect you want me to support your claim
to the throne of the Iron Islands my
claim yes
what's wrong with you so Yara owed that
to Daenerys and as you would expect
Gendry was still loyal to Daenerys
because Daenerys is ploy to secure his
allegiance by legitimizing him in naming
him Lord of storms and in the Stormlands
was successful overwhelmingly successful
I think you should be Lord of storms end
that can't be Emma busted no you are
Lord again dree Baratheon of storms end
the lawful son of Robert Baratheon
because that is what I have made you a
fitting reward for a hero the Lord of
storms and who would be forever loyal to
you see you know anyone who's that was
the whole reason for this scene here
during the banquet so the Gendry would
be a powerful player in the future that
she knew would support her in all of her
actions so the logic of Jon Snow taking
the black at the end would have made a
little more sense if they'd given Gendry
a couple lines of dialogue implying that
if justice were not served Yara Gendry
in the other Daenerys supporters like
grey weren't the unsullied the Dothraki
would match the other forces the Starks
and the people that supported Jon Snow
in another Civil War and they didn't
want another conflict right after having
this one there were a lot of people
after the episode that are like well
wait a minute it's not like grey worm is
going to send someone to check on Jon Snow to make sure that he's still at the wall
why did wouldn't he just turn back right
around it's because Gendry and Yara were
really upset about the fact that there
wasn't any justice so they accepted the
compromise because Jon Snow was taking
the black but also was part of this
scene number one they make sir Jorah
take the black so that when Jon Snow
ghost in torment had that final scene
where the gate at Castle black is rising
up in there riding north of the wall
just like the very first scene from the
pilot episode surged or is there with
them riding north of the wall - just
like his father the old bear so he would
have become part of the Nights Watch
just like the old bear but here's the
thing though when they were explaining
this alternate ending even though they
knew what was going on with Jon Snow's
future after this moment in the
alternate ending they had no idea what
Joris future was going to be with his
life at the Nights Watch even the actor
Ian Glen is like you know after this you
know who knows what happens to Sir Jorah
him just living out the rest of his life
ranging north of the wall they also
clarify - what's going on with Johnson
here too in talking about this surge or
alternate ending basically John snow has
taken the black and he's just going to
be ranging the far north for the rest of
his life
still no intention on having children or
anything like that he's honorable he's
still going to hold those vows but like
tormund says he has the real north in
him so they're going to be ranging all over
the far north with the rest of their
life because even though the white
walkers are dead there's still a lot of
dangerous things living north of the
wall that he'll need to protect the
wildlings from so it's not that he's
just protecting the realm as part of
this newly reformed Night's Watch
he's also protecting all these free folk
too so in awe there was a lot of
confusion about what Jon Snow was doing
next is he leaving the Nights Watch is
he going to be king of the free folk like
mance rayder now it seems to imply based
on what they've said recently that that
was not the case like he's just going to be
arranging the far far north for the rest
of his life so let me know in the
comments which ending you like better
the one where Sir Jorah lives and gets
to live out his life at the Nights Watch
or the original ending where he dies
protecting Daenerys before he watches
her go full dictator the after England
actually says that it's the sweet ending
sparing him from watching Daenerys go to
darkness so he actually likes the
original way that things went down he
was always on my death predictions list
and everything that I think that he'd
done as a character up to season 7 when
he returned to dinners made it seem like
his only real remaining wish was to die
serving her which he did so I do think
his original ending as we saw it was
better than the alternate one even
though would have been cool to see him
riding north of the wall with John Plus
people already complaining that too many
big characters survived the battle with
the White Walkers can you imagine if
another big one had survived it would
have been ridiculous as we learn about
more deleted scenes and alternate
endings things like that as the blu-ray
gets ready to drop I'll do videos for
all that stuff but leave your requests
in the comments below I was planning on
doing a game of Thrones Q&A for the
finale today till we learned about this
alternate ending so I'm still going to do
that either tomorrow or the next day
after that leave all your questions in
the comments that you want me to include
in that video
congratulations Gaara Alvarez or the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details while you wait for
everything click here for the trailer
for the Game of Thrones season a bonus
episode and a big update on what's going
on with the Game of Thrones prequel
series the Blood Moon show
and click here for my Game of Thrones
finale and easter eggs video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!